um all right so for you is it now that
you're on Goliath
is it more
because like like this last album we've
been talking about for a while has been
finished for a while right yep are you
going to
try to get another album the next like
six months or what is the plan probably
not probably but then the next well the
next six months will be the beginning
you know on next year yeah next year
probably early next year mid Earl uh end
of winter next year to early spring
I'm hoping to drop another project does
Paul like ever give you any feedback
like yo M likes this song nah he don't
say nothing about him no I mean not that
he don't say nothing about him but
um
he really don't say nothing about him
yeah I would just I just wonder if he's
like hey yo check out this new guy on
Goliath like who also was almost unshady
who also tagged our door I'm sure who
also is equally as not that I'm sure I
don't I don't know I don't know we don't
like I you know I'm sure everybody asks
Paul about M for sure so I don't want to
be that guy as well as when I turn when
I do get the chance to speak to Paul
which is he's always a phone call away
he's great
great great great ahead of um the label
that I'm on I'm totally happy with it
but uh I'm talking about my [__] yeah
I'm busy like yo what's the play yo
what's up I need you to push this button
or because you know or we just
strategizing was there ever uh a bar in
the last like few years now you're more
well known that you just thought was too
crazy that you were like you know what
we're gonna take that bar off the end
there's a couple that I should have took
off that well there's like two verses I
took off the album and replaced
um but also listen I went up to Spotify
like two weeks ago and um Paul came with
me like that and that's like unheard of
that you have a label coming to meetings
with you which was dope but listening to
it in a room with two women and well I'm
talking about watch your mouth oh I'll
smack a [__] I'm on the front lines
like yo what's happening and I'm like
I'm like oh [__] this don't really hey
hey you're probably like yes
and then even Paul at one point was like
it's very tongue-in-cheek and it's very
you know I was like yeah it's almost
like you gotta like hey guys look
I'm about to play the song Yes or just
don't play that song
yeah it's like ah
oh [__]
yeah this is a long song Facts yeah like
hey we could just go to the next one
yeah yeah it just happened you guys
don't have to playlist this one like we
get it you know like I get it like you
know what I'm saying like you know it
also it might not even make the album
after all you know like just so you know
like I think we might take it off facts
when you sit in the meetings with the
with the corporations and these
different people you're like um maybe I
should have said a different
different rhyme right there but it's
cool it is what it is that's what makes
me [__] your life what um is the uh
uh classification between give me the uh
what what qualifies as a a feminine band
and a masculine bends C-Class is a
feminine band there's a it's for baby
mothers those are for single women girls
that do eyelashes and [__] like that you
know what I'm saying nail technicians
you know uh nurses assistant so whatever
nurse texts whatever the [__] Dental
technicians and all that that's two jobs
secretly no that's like X5 or x3 sx3
yeah it's cool X5 is decent X3 is
definitely X X5 is decent if you're
under
30. I'm saying after 30 bro you should
be getting it remember evidence from
Dilated Peoples talked about his X5 in a
rap verse ones
shout out to dilated people's facts
facts uh yeah so so C classes anything
outside of a C-Class is is uh
is passable I mean C-Class or under you
have like a truck for real like a
[__] man's truck what truck is it I
got a [__] Denali oh yeah you got the
[__] Denali bro that [__] is like
sitting in my living room I love that
[__] bro um and you got like yours you
still have you still had a camera [__]
on you no I'm saying I saw the rap but
you still keep like your [__]
products it's not as intricate as my
last truck
um but I still got merch in my back
because it kind of like makes your truck
not truckable anymore no you know it's
perfect because people
some some of my friends actually think
I'm gonna help them move or some [__]
like that so they're like yo you got the
pickup truck right nah bro it's my story
merch in the back of me go [__] yourself
why would you even ask me to help you
move anyway bro I'd rather pay somebody
to [__] move it for you like leave me
alone yeah I got other [__] to do facts
[__] your life yeah if you have a friend
that'll help you move that's a true
friend
I won't help you move but if you really
need it
I'm not aware
yeah like I'd rather pay even [__] in my
house sign goes [__] up in my house I
don't know how to fix that just call
call whoever just get it you're not like
a mechanical kind of no that's not my
style bro no my father died when I was
four bro my mother didn't know how to do
that [__] see you yo I'll be I feel like
I've gotten into like my uh era of life
where I feel like I'd be doing some man
[__] like I you know what I'm saying
like I can fix it a little bit but
YouTube man YouTube University YouTube
could do everything you could teach you
everything like I started grilling and
[__] yo see I don't even know how to do
that I just started bro started busy I
got that pellet grill I got that griddle
I got a nice Grill too I just never
Grill on it oh so so you get the griddle
though you could do the [__] Hibachi
in the backyard fire it's great